Hey everyone! We talked a good bit about uncertainty in a prior video and looked at when to pursue projects based on expected values. Let's keep in-line with that and now look at uncertainty and pricing.
To do so we will keep things simple by examining two types of consumers, though we can extend this beyond two.
We have a low value consumer and a high value consumer. The difference between the two is what they are willing to pay for the same item.
Here we are going to look at tacos because it's Tuesday when I'm making this.
We have Mr. Low and Ms High who both have a craving for tacos on the fabulous Taco Tuesday. They both like to go to the same restaurant—Tacorama—to enjoy these tacos.
The current deal is 3 tacos for $10. While Mr. Low does enjoy tacos, Low only wants to pay $6 for three tacos.
Ms. High enjoys tacos so much that she is willing to pay $10 for the tacos—her exact valuation. This leaves a bit of a conundrum for Tacorama.
This leaves a bit of a conundrum for Tacorama. How can they benefit from these transactions? They have two options. The first is to price the tacos at $6 and sell to both in exchange for a combined $12.
In this case, Tacorama is ensuring 100% certainty that both Mr. Low and Ms. High are going to buy the tacos. However, keep in mind that Tacorama incurs $3 in costs to both consumers.
Therefore we get a $6 total
profit.
If Tacorama instead prices high,
then only Ms. High buys at a price of $10. This leaves Tacorama with $7 in profit.
If Tacorama is trying to maximize its profit, then Tacorama should only price high. However, there is one thing we have forgotten about.
What if we could sell to each consumer at their willingness to pay?
This brings us to price discrimination. If Tacorama can sell to Mr. Low at $6 and Ms. High at $10, then they'll earn an extra $3 in profit over their next best alternative.
To do this does require a bit of work and understanding your consumer base. Let's first consider the case of arbitrage.
If Mr. Low can buy tacos at a lower price and sell them to Ms. High at a higher price, then Tacorama misses out on Ms. High's
higher valuation.
This is kind of like what Uber Eats and Doordash do. They serve as a middleman taking advantage of your higher valuation to stay at home as opposed to going to the restaurant.
The fees capture this. Next, if Ms. High learns of Tacorama offering lower prices, she'll of course want to purchase tacos at that lower price. What can Tacorama do?Tacorama can pursue a few strategies, and this isn't an exhaustive list.
First, they can offer the cheaper deal earlier in the day. Perhaps, Mr. Low is ok with eating early and Ms. High is not. This may prevent arbitrage and Ms. High seeking the lower price.  Tacorama may offer coupon or punch cards to entice Mr. Low into the restaurant.
This does create a problem of incentivizing Ms. High to use the coupon, so the restaurant would need to determine the discount that causes a coupon throwaway to the trash.
Tacorama may offer loyalty rewards to Ms. High if she continues to purchase at the higher price. Though the design of this type of program needs to dissuade Mr. Low from joining. Lastly, Tacorama can bundle the tacos with a drink such that a lower margin item (the tacos) are paired with a higher margin item (the drink) in an effort to recoup lost margins from the tacos. We'll talk more about these strategies and others later in the course.Alright, that's it. Hope you've enjoyed it and we'll catch you in the next one.